bye everybody the knights back at it
today with a full practice at city
national arena they are less than two
weeks away
from their first exhibition game against
arizona of course
they want to all be played in the hub in
edmonton the practices are going well
and at least one line that of mark stone
max pachuretti
and william carlson continues to click
those are at all times
back in february um started to generate
some chemistry
and maximum point together basically
because i got traded here um
carly does everything uh assists army
knife kills penalties
um gets in a power play scores goals
plays defense so
a lot of different elements in the line
i need to get back into that shape and
have all
all uh 33 guys ready to go and watch for
stoner to be named captain next season
just thinking about that okay
of course the nhl playoffs delayed
because of fears of coronavirus this is
not the first time the stanley cup
playoffs have been affected by a
pandemic more than a hundred years ago
the spanish flu hit
during the playoffs there's a new book
out 1919 the search for mankind's
greatest killer
author ken rosen talks about how the
pandemic
affected all sports at the time in the
stanley cup final between seattle and
the montreal canadiens
canadiens players got sick during a
train ride to the west coast
it canceled the final there was no 1919
champ crown
and it also proved to be fatal for one
canadian player
uh during game six a number of the
players get sick literally on the ice
um joe hall who's a brilliant and
incredibly gifted and incredibly nasty
defenseman for the montreal canadiens
passes out on the ice at the end of the
game it goes right to the hospital never
leaves
dies a couple days later and the couple
the other players got sick the general
manager gets sick and they can't put a
team
on on the ice for the final game to
decide the stanley cup
so uh the cup series is cancelled in
1919
okay we're not trying to scare anybody
here that was 100 years ago
but babe ruth almost died twice while
with the red sox in 1918
he got the flu then he was treated with
silver nitrate and that almost killed
him
ruth went on to have a pretty good
career i believe with the yankees he
played a little bit later
did well